in march of 2019 my wife and i were
walking
together after just having finished a
4.4 million dollar month
and she turned to me and she said alex
let's just
shut it all down she's like i'm so tired
of this i'm so burnt out
i just don't want to do this anymore and
it was at that moment that i realized
that
in order to progress in the
entrepreneurial game we had to change
the way we operated the way we thought
and so if you're an entrepreneur or
you're a business owner
the number one thing that i've seen that
creates success is longevity meaning
that you can continue
to play the game because at the end of
the day none of us is going to quit
business or hopefully
not quit business and so in order to
decrease the likelihood that we quit
which is the only way to fail
we have to think through our problems
with a defined
framework and so rather than focus on
the actual framework of the decision
making what i want to do is focus
in around the state in which you can
manage your own thoughts
right and so um i've had to deal with
plenty of stressors as you can imagine
so if you're stressed in your own
business right now
like you know add a zero to whatever
your revenue is and you'll have ten
times the potential
for stress if you're ten times bigger or
a hundred times the stress
if you're 100 times bigger which depends
on who's listening
we may be that for you and so i can tell
you truthfully that the way that i've
been able to eliminate
pressure which has created longevity in
the game for me
has been through four strategies that
actually work in the real world for me
so the first that i do whenever i have
any kind of negative situation
is i go a thousand x negative all right
and then i re-evaluate so let me explain
what that means so if for example
there's something that's bad that
happens we get a bad review or we get
you know a client's upset or i have an
employee who says something bad to
another employer or employee that's key
leaves
or someone tries to you know a
competitor steal stuff and then starts
back
whatever it is right there's a million
problems in go business or you have cash
flow issues or
where you can't make payroll whatever it
is right
i like to think of this one as my first
this is my like my first line of defense
the first thing i think about is
if this were to happen a thousand times
more right
and this works really well with what i
would consider like minor to
medium-sized grievances
so things that happen that are kind of
everyday business that can you know
bother you for a day
or two days or a week right well if you
can just
shorten that loop of that cycle of you
being disturbed because the thing is
lots of those things are going to happen
every single week a lot of times you
just don't know about them right
depending on the size of your business
and so i just happen to know about it
now and so
first off i like to think about that but
second is i'll do this right which is
i'll imagine
that every day in my life this happens
whatever that thing is
right uh customer's upset now obviously
if it's a core issue you have to resolve
it but
in terms of like it happening in my
affective or my emotional reaction to it
then i think to myself well if this
happened every single day and this
happened every hour of every day at some
point i would become desensitized to it
right because i had so much stimulus of
this
i would not be able to have an emotional
response and so when i think and i
imagine myself experiencing this
negative thing over and over and over
and over again it's called negative
visualization
then what ends up happening is i become
immune to it and so i think to myself
well if i can become immune to it after
a thousand tries
i can become immune to it on the first
try because it means nothing has
actually changed to only my perspective
on the occurrence and in so doing you
can short wire yourself to that end
outcome and then fast forward it to the
present so you can live the rest of your
day or less
of your week without being emotionally
disturbed and when you do that at least
for me
i feel like i make better decisions and
so i think for most of us as
entrepreneurs and business owners
we are judged by the marketplace by the
quality of our decisions that's
ultimately what it is right it's just
how good
are the quality of the decisions that we
make and so if i can decrease the
likelihood that i make bad decisions and
i can do it on a regular basis then this
is something that protects my mind
and candidly it's what makes life worth
living the second thing
that i'll do is that when i'm preparing
for something
that that i need to start doing right
because there might be habits or things
that you need to start doing you know
this is a
this is a slightly different example but
it's i'm giving you the four different
strategies that have worked really well
for me
the second one is let's say you wanted
to start working out because you're like
you know what i've been neglecting my
health or
you know start eating healthy whatever
it is right those are fitness examples
but just go with me
what i will do is i will expect the
worst
circumstance all right so rather than
saying okay
i'm going to go work out and feel
excited right to go work out i'm super
pumped
what i want to do is i want to plan and
prepare my mental state
for when it times to work out when it
comes time to work out i'm going to be
exhausted
i'm not going to have slept well i'm
going to have a lot of business stress
and so i have to expect that going into
every workout
now if i don't have that happen then
it's a bonus
rather than expecting nothing to be my
my mental state
and then when something bad does happen
then i have this reason
right and so it it literally does go
into truly expecting
the worst case scenario and making the
pre-formed decision
to act anyways despite that because you
have planned for it
so most people most humans have really
good psychological resilience
if we brace for it so if you're about to
give someone bad news for example you
actually have to let them hey this is
bad news hey you might want to sit down
for this
because people actually are very
resilient if you give them a moment to
emotionally brace themselves
and so what we're doing here is using
this bracing technique on ourselves
in advance of a situation that is likely
to occur
at some time between now and when we die
especially if it's a habit that has to
be ongoing
right and so what i do is i emotionally
brace
for the worst scenario all right that's
number two
the third thing that i do and this is
probably the one that i use the most
it's really the one that i use the most
actually i'll i'll say that one for last
a a different version of this the
emotional brace is
an extreme version right so kind of this
is imagine the thing that you just said
happen that bothered you
for a thousand times then it stops
affecting you the second one is you
emotionally brace yourself
the third one
is you imagine worst case all right now
the point here
is kind of like a pain anchor okay and
so what i mean by a pain anchor is
it gives you perspective on your current
issues right so for this for example
whenever you've had a family member die
or someone close to you die or some of
you even have a pet diet depends on
where you're at in your life right
if you have something that was painful
for you right all of us benefit we get
the gift of perspective from those who
die
that's like the one of the final gifts
that any death occurs that's in your
proximity will give you right
and so for me i think about that
negative situation i really like trying
and soak myself in it right really try
and like
put it on and walk around and what that
painful state would be whatever
whatever worst case scenario i could
imagine might be death of a spouse it
might be death of a
of a parent whatever right or a child
something horrific right
but if i can truly allow myself to go
there
then what happens is i get so much
context and perspective
on the little thing like somebody
bashing a piece of content or someone
saying that they hate your ad
or whatever it might be the thing that
is deriding you and all of a sudden
that problem becomes massively minimized
right
it becomes almost inconsequential and
what i found is that
over my life in the business there are
so many there's an infinite amount of
problems
truly like there's an unlimited amount
of problems i could think of so many
things we should be doing or we could be
doing better or should not have happened
right
but it's only because we put the word
should in front of it that we have an
expectation that is different than
reality which creates
the the friction in our minds creates
the dissonance it creates the
unhappiness that we have and so if i can
imagine the worst case scenario and then
actively minimize
my current situation then i usually can
get right through it
and most times what i what i found is
that most problems shrink into a
relevance
within broader context they actually
never get solved we just realize that we
just don't care
and that they are no longer meaningful
to us and so that has been something
that's been very useful for me as we've
grown
because frankly the bigger your company
gets the more ability and potential you
have to become stressed
and i think most of us are here for
freedom and so if you want freedom then
you have to
at least for me i have found that i have
to manage my mental state in order to
continue to make high quality decisions
and so that leaves me the last one which
is probably my my favorite and most used
one
that i use on on anything and this may
this may bother some of you and that's
okay this is an n
sorry universe is that
this is a this is a world view that i
have so if you are if you are
you know don't don't be trigger you know
don't
don't take offense to this but i'm
telling you what has worked for me
and so i believe that the universe will
continue to expand
until eventually everything becomes a
fine mist over a long enough time
horizon
the sun will give out all stars will
extinguish and then everything will just
become a fine mist
and as silly as that may sound it means
that
anything that we do this video anything
that i accomplish in this world
will eventually disappear and be
meaningless and so
some people find that incredibly
depressing i don't
i find that to be incredibly meaningful
because it means to me
that i'm allowed to i am the only person
that ascribes meaning
to anything because it means that
nothing has inherent meaning
and so that means that when i have any
stressors in my life i'm saying that i'm
choosing my brain is choosing to make
meaning out of this
when there was no meaning to be made to
begin with and so by doing that i can
play the notes of the piano of meaning
that happen across the occurrences and
circumstances in my life
and so when i think about it in this
context everything shrinks into a
relevance and so
a lot of the the concepts around like i
want to build a legacy i want
i want to make an impact i want to leave
a dent in the universe
you're not you're probably not going to
leave it done in the universe and even
if you made some big
advancement within 500 years like it'll
probably be forgotten
and that would be like if you're the top
point zero zero zero zero one percent
right it's unlikely but it is a hundred
percent likely
that over a long enough time horizon
everything will disappear
right and by doing that for me it
decreases the pressure
that i put on myself for having to i
must i should i have to
like i can't live without those thoughts
that strangle me right those are the
things that destroy
my ability to make decisions because i
become way more emotional as a result of
them
and so whenever i have any kind of
negative occurrence or any stressors
that come up in my life which are
inevitable
i use this as my ultimate frame of
reference this is my ultimate trump card
that i use to keep my
my emotions at bay and ultimately say
i am the master of my own universe i get
to decide what has meaning
and for me i'll tell you what what what
i have found most meaningful for me is
that my purpose in life
to to my knowledge at this point is to
learn
i love learning and so that is that is
why i make these videos because i feel
like i am able to
better learn how to think i'm better on
how to run businesses i'm a better learn
i can better
learn all of the aspects of everything
by teaching it right and
i'm sure if you ever did a book report
when you were in high school you learned
the one chapter you had to do your book
report on or give a presentation on way
better than any of the other chapters
because when you have to teach something
you have to learn it better
you have to learn the nuances of what
makes something work
and so for me even cataloging these
things been useful for me because i
think these are all the things that i do
huh but now i have a process that i can
continually use
use haphazardly just because i've just
trained myself over time doing this and
so
i don't know where you're at in your
business career if you're you know
you're at seven figures you're at eight
figures or multi-figures you have
multiple companies whatever it is right
this has been so personally impactful
for me
that it has helped me be in this for the
long haul
because if nothing has meaning except
for what i
choose to give meaning then it means i
can choose to only play games
that i find meaningful and by extension
i will not fall out of the game or quit
because the thing that i'm doing is the
thing that
that i derive the most meaning from and
so i will be able to outlast
longer players pursuit and what happened
is
for me my life becomes a glorification
to an idea faster and break through the
bottlenecks that you have so you can so
for me like this i will you know we'll
do every time i can check out one of my
uh my next videos that are coming out
as i'm going through courses the lessons
that i have more engaging more
entertaining more educational have more
stories
woven into them so that hopefully i can
transfer these things to someone else
because that is what i find meaningful
not because it is eternally
meaningful but just because that ideal
to me has meaning
and so um that is something that i
believe is eternal values are eternal
values in the universe and so for me i
choose to dedicate my content
to those ideals and so anyways i hope
you find value in this i hope this is
interesting to you subscribe like all
that jazz
um and have an absolutely wonderful day
where you can create all the meaning you
want
or remove all the meaning from the
negative things that occur in your life
using some of these four hacks so lots
of love keeping awesome and i'll catch
you in the next vid bye